so the new Quantum Leap is out and we're
getting a lot of comments saying that it
is a load of woke garbage but I'm going
to argue that it kind of has to be but
it also should be anti-woke so let's
have the debate welcome to Sidetrack you
have Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so I'm going to say first of all I'm not
trying to upset anyone I am just sharing
my opinion on this subject I am not
going to go into the political nonsense
again I have done a video of my thoughts
about woke and the use of this word I
don't like it but we can move on
I'm going to talk about the TV show
because
I honestly think Quantum Leap should be
a bit woke and it should be anti-woke it
should upset both sides of the aisle
because the original show always kinda
did now I would argue that Quantum Leap
originally was a bit woke but within the
confines of what was sort of allowed
back then you remember this was the 90s
it was really limited by what the senses
at the time would allow on Prime Time
television so it could never quite push
the boundaries as far as any new TV show
can if they choose to
but Quantum Leap even back then did push
the boundaries it did you know talk
about the Vietnam War in a very negative
way it did explore sort of gender roles
sexism it explored racism a lot you know
so it did talk about a lot of these
subjects that are plaguing our screens
today
but I would argue even though it touched
on subjects that you know some people
might call woke it always put the story
first there was always a moral dilemma
or a bad guy to defeat or some problem
for Sam to overcome but that was the
point of Quantum Leap it was the point
of the story so therefore I would argue
it was never really woke because it
always put the story first and if the
new series does the same I will argue
again that it's not woke I've not seen
it yet Matt has so the jury's out on
that for me just yet I will argue
anytime that if an agenda is put before
the story then I don't want to watch how
to load of crap
but Quantum Leap is one of those TV
shows that I would genuinely argue
should annoy both the extreme of the
right wing and the extreme of the left
wing it should kind of annoy people that
go hand in hand sing in Kumbaya with
flowers around their necks going oh
political correctness it should kind of
annoy those people because it should
challenge those people to sort of
reconsider the way they think but it
should also challenge the people on the
other side of the argument that are
shouting that everything that Hollywood
is producing at the moment and honestly
I get comments from some people that do
generally say that everything is and no
exceptions everything that's that coming
out TV shows moment is just work rubbish
and I think most moderate people or most
thoughtful people would agree that
that's not really true but the really
hardcore of either side of this argument
should really get irritated by a show
like Quantum Leap because it really
should challenge both sides of that
debate this is a perfect TV show because
actually it's kind of the point of
Quantum Leap is to go in and to talk
about cultural Social Challenges and to
sort of try to find a way to resolve
them because that's what Sam was always
trying to do he jumped into people's
lives and he tried to resolve whatever
problem it was that they were facing and
to make their lives hopefully by the end
of the episode a bit better I honestly
believe that a lot of shows at the
moment are really starting to poke fun
at the people that do shout woke a lot
you know She-Hulk at the moment is
actually purposely and not subtly poked
fun at them I I don't think that's fair
because I genuinely think there is an
issue within Hollywood that needs
addressing that these people are
highlighting I obviously don't agree
with the use of the word and I explain
that in another video but I do agree
that there's a problem
so
for me Quantum Leap if it's going to be
a success should really annoy both
extremes of that argument
so let's see if it actually has the
balls to challenge these arguments let's
see if it has the balls to do what it
did before and try to push the envelope
as much as possible and actually explore
lots of the problems that our culture is
currently facing because if it doesn't
it will completely fail to be honest
it's going to completely fail anyway
because Dean Stockwell isn't in it and
Dean Stockwell carried that show for me
I mean don't get me wrong Sam Beckett
Scott Bakula is cool but Dean Stockwell
was the man and nobody ever noticed that
this mountain over here is a health and
safety nightmare why is it glowing
people are working in there
don't get it so please get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think
oh boy I'm not looking forward to
reading some of them and please try to
remember that I am just talking here and
this is just my opinion don't get angry
I want to have a conversation I want to
have the debate I really don't want to
start any arguments
so get in the comments and let's have
that discussion if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really helps us out
also if you want to become a fully
fledged side tracker because you enjoy
the content that much hit the join
Button as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]